When I play pickleball, I don't want anybody to know that I'm playing pickleball. It's more like knuckleball
It's time to thank you the ice cream truck drivers. Thank you so much ice cream truck drivers out there
Who are the ice cream truck drivers? Why these are the folks that bring that fucking ice cream straight to your fucking ear holes right now
I'd like to thank bearded scoop three blue line scoop chasing the dragon scoop
Christine Alcester Christie Salinas Darren Cunningham Garth scooper David Walker dead
Laszlo and dirty old scoop if you want to be an ice cream truck driver
Just like these fine folks and I hope you do
Head over to preaching fun comm preaching fun comm is where you can go to sign up to be an ice cream truck driver
And who knows the life you save?
Maybe your own
Jacob are we on twitch?
We're not but we're about to be because I forgot to here we go
Hey, Johnny, do you want to go to an ice cream social? Yeah, I'd love to great. Let's go
Its time for Matt Mattingly's ice cream social sitting over in Pittsburgh. It's Paul Mattingly sitting in Las Vegas
It's Matt Donnelly also in Las Vegas. It's me Jacob the audio guy. We're preaching fun. We're preaching fun
That's what they say everybody. That's what they claim
That is what they claim fun preaching
the fun all the time
Did you guys read the story about they're going nuts that a wolf figured out how to pull in a crab trap have we seen this
Yes. Yes, this is great. So tell us a wolf has
Basically saw a wolf saw humans set a crab trap into a lake and then and then when the hunters went away or the
Hunt the hunters. They use the great crab hunters
Their cage of little meat there's a there's a bar right on East Sahara called the great great crab hunter
The bar in front of the flamingo was called the crab hunter
When the crab trap setters walked away
The wolf went over and then started pulling in the rope and brought the trap up and the meat that was set inside the crab trap
Some scientists are going nuts being like this is a wolf using tools
Right, and I was skeptical about this being significant news
until
My cat Shmi ki
Figured out how to open the cat door that we close at night the dog. Oh
Yeah, so like we put a little slide down the thing to seal off the
Cat door. It's really a doggie door, but we've repurposed it for cats by not having dogs and having cats
By having in a cat store and
We were hearing this noise whatever we thought was just playing for something downstairs getting fixated on something, you know, like the like cats do
No, Shmi ki had figured out how to push up the the seal of the cat door enough to sneak out
middle of the night
To kill birds
That's probably to kill birds and it was not yeah in the chat. They're asking that you sure wasn't smokey
That's that's the hard part if my money would have been on Shmuki
She's the more devious ninja of the cats. She's certainly the most lethal of the cats
but no is a
Shmi ki want to go outside and so
Now it's all right Shmi ki. Yeah, and so now I'm thinking between that wolf story and my cat story
Maybe our time as as as apex predators on this planet is is is you know, there's one time we weren't right, you know
Right historically our species would hang out wait for the bigger predators be done
Then we'd go in and pick the bones and drink the bone marrow of leftover victims and and then and then we figured out tools
And and now oh wait, is that what we're supposed to be doing waiting on to suck the bone marrow?
I think about that all the time, you know fancy steak house all these homeless dicks for no reason
You totally misinterpreted
Boy is there egg on my face that's I think about that whenever you're at a fancy steakhouse they offer that marrow
Like a marrow and bread appetizer. Yeah
I'm like man, what would like hundreds hundreds or maybe I guess it's thousands of years ago with thousand years ago
Just think about like here. We are like almost like laughing at the fact that this is all we used to do
Yeah, now it's just an appetizer. We dip our bread in
over fancy clothes
Bone marrow
Anyways, I think these cats I think I think animals are just gonna start figuring it out. Yeah, we've had a good run
We can be done with this as I'm for one. I'm ready to push eject. Yeah, let's let's run for the hills
Let them do the best new apex predator or raccoons best apex animal on the planet raccoons
Good love
Would love it would love it raccoons cuz they're almost there. Their hands are almost there. Yeah, it's very close
They're getting domesticated as we speak. I can easily see
Raccoons like you know, just a raccoon city
That you don't want because that leads to Resident Evil
Manatees that's where that's where it all goes down in Raccoon City. Oh
Don't you know your Resident Evil lore
Sadly, I'm lacking. Oh man
Resident Evil was it that was it. God damn when that game came out
Oh, and then you had to get the second version to do with the dual stick. Oh my god. Oh, oh, oh
Every time I see the videos or the the video of somebody like handing a raccoon cotton candy
Next to a stream and they wash it it goes away. So say breaks my heart every time
It's the saddest thing ever and but you have that raccoon some some food that can be washed
Yep, shame upon all those people that do that. We had to lose a tree yesterday. Oh
Yes, I see it. Well, I thought it was in the yard and then all of a sudden and like it just no
We had lawn service come out cuz it was starting a suckle took our tree
It was starting to crack and get real rotty. It was already rotty and we knew it was gonna go at some point
But also it was already dead. But yes, but at the last last couple of months it started to straight-up crack up top
Yeah splint and if that thing would come down on a pooch. I'd never let myself
Forgive myself. So
We got the pros in to come in and do it and we left a four foot tall stump
Or so four foot tall stump so we can fart around and put birdseed on top of that or maybe a little you
You left that on purpose on purpose. Yes, we left a four foot and we left all the wood
so we've got logs and logs and logs and sticks and twigs and
Ted is having a field day and he's out there getting a new chew toy every every other would precariously on a shelf
That's rickety that could collapse and kill one of his dogs. Yep
All the logs are safely on the ground they're part around with them though, but now we're gonna use that to
Re-border the garden in this springtime and
we're gonna chop up the twigs even more for mulch and for birdies to use and then the
Little sticks we're gonna figure out other uses for it
But it's great and the fact that and so into the gardening stuff
We could just have them leave all the wood and not just chuck it in their truck and chip it
I'm like, yeah, just leave it. We're fine. So do you have a fireplace or a fire pit or anything like that?
We don't but our
Relatives do so if we wanted to if you set that wood on fire, you could you could have one done
We could just set it on fire and burn a patch in the yard and done and done
We could do that. I don't trust my dogs not to
Burn themselves. They're dumb jump into the fire
I wouldn't jump into the fire, but they would fart around with it and they get in trouble
One of our dogs is fascinated by fire
Look our little lily dog is fat
Like I will have a fire going and she will just sit and watch it
She will get close to it. She won't she won't like get get dangerously close to anything
But she will just sit and watch it with this fascinated look on her face. That is some way that is some ancient
Breeding in there, right? Like like how many out of me? Well, I mean, that's it. How many no, no, no, no
No, this is Lily's been going the dispensary when Jacob's not home
Getting that sticky like look inside the flames
It speaks to you
Also wolf cuz I'm a dog Lily is that girl with the balloon at the concert
Jason is gonna be holding the balloon in her mouth
You know what I'd be in I'd be in so yeah, there was a fancy
Starbucks barista cup that came out. I
Saw this I have already lodged a formal complaint and since cease and desists to all Starbucks
Good. Yeah, cuz our IP
Not our IP our our IP should stand for something
Alright, our IP basically. Wait, what is that? What is it called? It was a barista. It's a glass
Cup that's a it's like it looks like a honey jar
but then it's got a little beanie hat on top and a straw and
This thing sold out immediately. I think it was 30 bucks
Okay, of course, it's going for like multiple hundreds online. It's already a collector. People are insane. Yeah, as they were very
shortly stocked right, of course
engineered scarcity is the new normal in the dying days of capitalism here and
so
As you can imagine
That's it. I
Don't think it was the one with the sombrero, but it was one of the beanie hat, but as you can imagine
people being people don't understand that
Workers at the Starbucks don't really have any control over how many or where or who has bought the bear already. Ah, sure
So I will keep this I will keep this as vague book as possible. Okay, but I will say that within
The tri-state area an
incident occurred
where a woman
Physically attacked a store manager for not having the bay. Oh
my god
Pushed her against some fucking shelves and shit like out-of-hand bullshit behavior from this customer
Yeah, we got sorry just carry more tasers on us I think just making that more common
Something man. It's just getting stupid. Well, I mean
Forget it your hands to yourself
It's just yeah, and then the manager
Bear cups and keep your hands to yourself. No Leon
They did not retaliate as is the way and we can't really it's just awful. Yeah
Anytime I hear those stories. I try to picture that person
Telling like they went home that night right or they went and met a friend later, you know
And then they're like like you think they have friends. I don't think they have friends
What I'm trying to get it. It's like what the hell is that version of that story where they're like, what's right?
They have the nerve to not have a grizzly barista mug
And so I attacked her. So I attacked it. They're like good for you, man
Stand up for yourself
Like the only thing that I see that's similar is the magic and Pokemon card stuff working retail now
That's just the craziest. I
was lucky they would we got a restock and I was able to grab a couple of booster packs to like a normal human being and
That's the limit you're supposed to be able to get and you know
The new Pokemon cards came out and I grabbed a couple booster packs and then you know the next day everything's gone
You know hundreds and hundreds of cards everything but it's it's all scalpers. They just come in and grab it all up and
Hock it on the internet for a crazy money. It's just nuts
Briar horse fans. They don't just fight they joust. They actually will take up a long
Spear from the ends of the room and they will gallop towards one another and fight. That's right fight for Briar horse
Now the Briar horses are the little miniatures, right? Yeah the miniature the collectible miniature horses
Yeah, they don't have they don't have horse beans. They have little horse English peas
Mushy peas, that's right. That's right. Look at the horse beans and this one's cock. I'll pay $50, please
Yeah, so my nod knock scoop is saying I saw a pic of someone weighing Pokemon packs
I guess depending on the weight some are more viable than others. Yes
That is what it's come to the scalpers go into the stores and they want individual packs to see which ones are heavier because that
Indicates a you know a coating of some kind with a metallic shine or something like that
And that's how they get the greater value cards for what they're buying man
When I was a bartender people asked for like all drums or all wings for their buffalo wings. I would get pissed at that
I can't imagine
Forget it forget it and that's just it like retail don't pay enough for people to be babysitting these 40-year-old motherfuckers
A guy got in the habit of coming in asking for all drums and like we didn't know what to do
So we kept accommodating him and Billy Tierney was in one night. He goes wait
Are you the guy ordering all drums? He goes he goes no stop. We can't do it. You get whatever ways you get
It's done. Hell. Yeah
Tierney is my hero. There are arguments to be made that flats are superior to drums. Yeah. Well, I do like a flat
Well, we knew the person was a you know, a knuckle-dragging ogre. We knew that already
Yeah
No taste
Right, right, right, but
Yeah, I did get a nice card out of one of my packs which was cool. I got a
The managers of that store. So this guy has a scale has to be like get out
No
No, they should be is what you should be but but no, but no, but who cares
Ultimately, who cares if they're buying this shit? I mean, it's it's frustrating. It's awful, but it's the end of the world man
All bets are off
Nobody's got it. No, who's got a dog in this fight?
You're gonna stop this guy from earning an extra $20. Fuck it, man
If that's what he's chosen to do if he's really chosen to go, you know what you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna fuck over every kid and collector that I know and
I'm gonna get five dollars
or
$20 for all this headache and bullshit. I'm gonna go to how do they do it?
If you said that there's a limit on how many they can buy
How do they how do they go in and buy a bunch of transactions Jacob multiple transactions?
What yep different cards different shit they just
You just shed on my point and being like no you can't do that and then you just went off about how these people are
Dickheads anyway, which one is there? Are they should we should?
I'm saying they're dickheads. Anyway, it is not in your favor to try and stop their dickish behavior. I don't think yes
It is in my store. It is I don't want to take your dickheads. I want to store. Okay. Okay, man
You're saying you're saying in your store. What is this your store you're talking about?
Elaborate your store. Tell me thank you for asking and I'm glad you guys could all be here
Did you guys know that Pokemon cards are a six billion dollar a year industry in sharks?
You can get it on the ground level
With I what I call house of shards house of shards is my card store. All right house of shards
Yeah, and and basically in there everyone has to get be I have a good attitude in the store
Or I punch them in the intestines until they shart in a game of death in the doorway. So it's fair
So it's a gentleman's game
We're all in for a gentleman's game in the store. Great. Okay in your store
Yes, you have the ability to say fuck you get out of here. Behave yourself
Don't be but also I promise you all of your product is behind glass and weigh the fuck away from their fingers in
Always that what's gonna have to happen
Are these fucking cards gonna have to get put in the glass cases and many are already open them up many are
Oh, of course they are and most of them are spiderwebbed up with those, you know magnetic steely deelys
Oh, so they can't pocket them. Yeah. Yeah, and what well in the end all kind of stuff and they got you know security stuff
but the stuff is going for crazy money out the gate now anyway, like even just basic basic prices for bundles or get are
getting very close to $100 for a box and
certainly over a hundred for a box of
Packs, but even just a basic box with like nine packs in it. It's like eighty five ninety dollars. It's nuts
so what you're saying is that this is happening at like target or
Walmart Walmart. Yeah, that's where it's really Walmart's really cracked down
my Walmart has everything behind a register like there's one register at the end of the wall and it's like
Tobacco products on register porn magazines trading cards. That's it. It's all the very
Porn magazines behind those registers
The day we have eight dollar long sleeve fake Budweiser t-shirts go steal those get out of here
Over there
So much
So much better stuff to be stealing. It's just terrible. It's just terrible. It's also
So the experience is I walk into a Walmart. They've now put these cards behind glass
I have to like push a button for one of the Walmart workers to come over with a key
Oftentimes. Yes, it is oftentimes and even then that person with a key they go. Hold on. I'm actually gonna weigh them before
Sometimes these motherfuckers are trying way. I'm yeah. Yeah, and then
If you're the guy with the key you have to just say like no here you're here you're - that's if that's what you want
That's what you gotta get. That's what they try and they try and do that somewhat
But also I went to my Walmart with a bathroom scale and I asked the person opening the glass to step on the scale
And he said you you misread the article that you read sir
You're you're not supposed to weigh me. You're supposed to weigh the packs of cards
So that's what you see you have him stand on the scale and hold his hands out
Okay, all right just hold so I gotta get a good read here, you know, they bring the little the little you know iron chef
I should have brought a digital bathroom. That's what they have this analog bathroom scale is not working
Well, they have the tiny little iron chef. I bought I brought a seesaw and some dumbbells. This is really not the way
Just this scale I'm gonna stand here blindfolded holding this thing out you tell me where the two sides are
Yeah, you're gonna just do two packs at a time and see which one's heavier and and then keep going on
Ridiculous yes chaotic points on chat that I used to do a trick with weight and I was clearly just trying to find the
graphic audience members versus the regular audience members
Need those hollow foils, baby, you know eat them we need them
Yeah, but I pulled a $25 card. Just grab me a couple packs. I wasn't you know looking for anything. You're rich
You're always exactly you're always looking for stuff, but you know, just grab a couple but what evs it's crazy
The whole thing is crazy, but I have a box of a figure like a rich person of
Pokemon and magic cards. Is there someone who like you like who like you follow on Instagram because they take their jet
Is who is there a Warren Buffett of Pokemon cards? Yeah, kinda Logan Paul
Okay, have you seen his entrance? I was okay with the question. I'm disappointed with the
When he was doing his boxing, I guess his brother has continued with it more
but when he started off with his boxing and stuff and his entrance stuff he had a
Oh, that's right. He had a first edition charizard on a gold chain around his neck
His big fucking flex the other person I get such on the magic side Paul brothers if they're fucking crazy
There's only funny I think they're so evil but
That's really funny to come out with Charizard it is funny and then they're good at being the bad guy wrestlers in real life
I guess when I say I'm conflicted by the Paul brothers, I mean starting now starting this, okay
There's the first thing that I was like, oh, that's actually kind of funny. Well, you know post Malone
He's a giant magic head did you know that I did know that yeah
Yeah, he bought the one ring from the first Lord of the Rings
Special set that came out. Oh man. He spent like two million dollars to buy that fucking card
That that's a card. Yeah, I thought you mean like he bought a movie proper. No, no, no, no
no, they made one card of the one ring some guy found it in a pack and
Oh, they only made they only made one because it was the one ring and they only made one car to that whole set and
Post Malone was like I'll take that please and he bought it. So he owns that he is crazy, but posty at least
Plays there's a lot of there's a couple channels
I follow easier time explaining to SJ that you spent two million dollars on the card
Or you beat up a manager at Starbucks because they didn't have the mug you're trying to buy which would need to get a manager
The manager nope that the manager would be a much easier explanation to SJ
Should be like you're an idiot and you're and you're gonna go to jail for like 30 days now
I'll see you when you get out and you're still dumb if I did the card thing
I think she would be so confused while she was divorcing me
Like
Does that person feel like they were like this the manager secretly had it was hiding it from them
Like like like they know you've got more of these cups like taking a person like oh you won't sell me the barista
You're waiting for the the nice. Yeah, or they think that the employees get first dibs or some shit
it's fucking crazy, which they do but
But they're not gonna know but they're not gonna spend
Two hours worth to pay for a fucking bear cup most of the time, right?
I remember a certain collector shit came in to the Starbucks. I worked at we actually couldn't get it
We actually weren't allowed to buy stuff or we went on to buy it with a customer discount. We had to buy it right price
Yeah, oh I see. Yeah, there's all kinds of rigmarole around it. It doesn't it's not enticing for
Employees to nab the super juicy exclusive. That's why I had a house of shards. You'll see a specific section of Starbucks collectibles
Fantastic behind the glass obviously always behind the glass and I won't let anyone who weighs more than 200 pounds go into that area
Justice is happening
I'll tell you who else loves a good house of shards and that is the following sponsor today's show is brought to you by
a
Guy who really guy who's really into women's beach volleyball try to convince you it's because of the sport not anything else
That's from the gorilla dentist in the Bjork video in 2025
It's guy who's really into women's beach volleyball try to convince you it's because of the sport and not anything else
Hey, man, come over this weekend watch a little watch a little game. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, though. It's a
Saratoga versus the renegades
Uh-huh. Yeah, it's gonna be watching you're watching college beach volleyball bash on the beach, baby
This is the big one. This is the big one. Uh-huh. Yeah, this is the one where those those college students are in tiny little bikinis
Right. I mean, that's why you watch that. Hey
This girl's very aerodynamic when they're up there getting ready for the spike. That's what I'm saying
It's kind of like swimmers. They got to wear the right kind of stuff
They got to shave their pubes and stuff, you know, so there's no less drag, you know
You know what pubedrag I
Wasn't aware of the pubedrag factor and oh man, it's it's it can cut fractions of seconds off your time
Yeah. Yeah, how many?
fractions
Okay, good. Hey if you want to stay if you want to stay for lady diving that comes up at 10 we can watch that too
Totally down. No, but first and foremost you got to bring some of the goods who's bringing the volley chip
Huh? Who's got the volley chips? What are volley chips? It's just chips
But I call volley chips cuz we're watching volleyball. I I brought Tostitos. I
Guess that'll have to work
Check it out. Check it out. Check what I got. Check what I got. See this back candy right here. Yeah
Gabby Reese's Pieces
Hell yeah
Got ourselves a night now. We got ourselves a fucking party
But I'm not watching just for the hot girls. I swear you got you brought Twix. I brought Twix
Yeah, yeah, no if you get four of them, it's good. Let's both try to get the twigs at the same time one two three
That's cuz my pubedrag it's all right here we each get two twigs and we can scissor them
It's good stuff
The Swiss let's scissor our Twix tonight together guys, huh be fun. I sure love volleyball
Just love volleyball
Scissor me Twix
Well, you know one's a lefty one's a righty so, you know, that's right that's right that's right
Do you want to have a nice scissory Twix Christmas this year, but you're not sure just what you're gonna do
Go over to scoop group. You can sign up for the scoop Secret Santa
Go over there. There are links all over scoop group
You can also if you're not on Facebook, you can go through Myra on Instagram
Go through scoop Myra on Instagram
It is the eighth annual scoop Secret Santa
2025 that is the whole thing and there are a couple of different things you can do three different
Things you can do you can do the Oh Mario is also saying also on discord
There are three different things you can do you can do the the whole general, you know, just the regular scoop Secret Santa
It's awesome scoop seat send each other gifts. This is fantastic
there are also two options you can do adopt a scoop and adopt a kid and that means that if you are a little tight on
Resources this Christmas for either yourself or your children you can put them up on the the the scoop
Adopt-a-scoop thing on there on the scoop Secret Santa thing and scoops will adopt you they will adopt your kids. They'll adopt you and
If you have scoops adopt your children, they do get full parental rights. You should know
What I think it's gonna toy I don't I don't I think it's gonna
It's not the it's not an actual adoption. No, no, no
What are we even talking about? This is just a trial run next year's full adoptions
Christmas through our Christmas party, and it's also you want to get in first now. So you have first dibs next year
Next year, it's a white elephant orphans where we get to figure out who wants what orphan. Those are the rarest orphans
You switch or those get those get poached so quickly in the wild. I can't hide
Basically there that's right out there with their little red eyes scampering in the dark poor things can't see for shit
Oh, I love them man
Giving so if you want to participate make sure you sign up by Thanksgiving to participate there do the scoop
Secret Santa do the adopt a scoop and the adopt a kid. It's really great. We don't have anything to do with this
This is all just our wonderful community being our wonderful community
Yeah, Myra is doing a great job spearheading this and so we really appreciate this
But we love to talk about it because boy do you guys make us look good? Okay?
It's the day before Thanksgiving is the deadline the drawing is on Thanksgiving. Therefore. You have to set up for Thanksgiving. All right
There you go
American Thanksgiving American Thanksgiving Canadian Thanksgiving. That's a good November 27th. No, you have to set up by November 26th
That's how it works, that's how them dates work what what?
15,000 is the number of
reports that went into the Nevada DMV
Snitches line. Oh in the first month of the of the website being active
So people who don't know Nevada DMV has a snitch page on their thing
If you see a car without a registration or without current registration, you can report them
You can report your friends and neighbors. I know this is not this doesn't tie into any history at all
Just just report snitch on your friends and neighbors our friends
Multiple news outlets are reporting on this so they're getting the stats out
But they are not saying what's driving it like I they need to find some snitches and interview them
I need to know what is driving the snitchery
Because here's the other thing that people don't know about Las Vegas. We're famously we don't have
High taxes, you know no income tax that kind of stuff. So the only way the state makes money is off the DMV
So our our registrations are super expensive
crazy high and so
But our personalized license plates are cheap. Yes. Oh, that's true. That is true
I tried to get one out here and I was like sticker shock. No, thank you
So this is basically like a citizen driven tax hall for the state
Yeah, this is the weirdest thing. Oh
Ten scoop in the chat says to be fair fourteen thousand nine hundred eighty seven of them were just him fucking with me
This is never that explains all of the certified letters, but for example all of the downtown Las Vegas parking
Is already up on this like if you go into a parking garage and your cars are registered you would
The someone from the city will come into that parking garage and ticket you
Within it within a half hour. It's some bullshit and like I
That's basically how I get my $75 reminder that I haven't forgot to renew my car registration
Once every so often and it always happens by going downtown to do something or see something. Oh, yeah
It's always going to the bucket showed at the majestic round. We do a bucket show it cost Matt 75 bucks
Yeah, that's all we don't do them every week anymore we can't do we cannot do a bucket show every week
It's a loss leader and that's yeah
I
Ran it to our friends Scott and Hazel the other night
No, no scooper Nova girl
It's not $75 for the registration the ticket that they give you is $75 and then you have to go pay for your registration
Yeah, the ticket saying hey, you're not registered. I'm like a new car if you get like a new car
It's based on like how old your car is and how valuable it is
Yeah, but a new car in Las Vegas will be like five or six hundred dollars for a registry
Oh, no, it's more than that. What's going on? Yeah. Yeah
When we got cuz we got two new cars
This year. Yeah, it was about two thousand dollars to register both of them
each of them
Right now for both of them. Okay, it was about it was about it was about a grand a piece
Yeah, it was it was like six hundred something for the van when we got the van but yeah for the for just the year
Just a year. Yeah, just regular registration
That's oh, no, it's crazy. That's why it's such a drive
That's I'm saying like that's what that's what in terms of people listening to the story when we talk about it
Like what is driving this is that this is how Nevada makes money. This is not Nevada
This is how Nevada makes up for its taxes. This is a Nevada tax. Yes is what the DMV registration is. Yeah
So, uh, I went to the party in Las Vegas, oh good
Uh
so
speaker world's newest show is over at the Casablanca and it's just in what used to just be the walk-in bar area of
Opium
the little
Little side restaurant area in between the old showroom and the Superfica restaurant
Mm-hmm, and they have put together this really cool dinner and
It's a three course for course technically for course. You can't bread and olives as a course and as you know, that's my favorite course
Why wouldn't I count it?
Nope, no bone marrow with the bread and olives. No, no, it's an upgrade. It's an upgrade. You got to get the upgrade
But if you're at House of Sharks, the charcuterie board just comes with bone marrow. It's included. Boy your store your store is on his top-notch
That's a nice door. Yeah, I really want to go to this store
And everyone is just so nice
You know, it's like we set the bar it's like it's cheaper I think and
It's about it's still like, you know, it's 150 bucks, but
You pay that for tickets on this town to most things anyway without food. Yeah. Yeah, and honestly
It's the other part where you pay that for food in this town without entertainment
Right. Yes, so you're getting one of those things at a deep discount. Yeah, and so it's just really intimate space
I think the place holds maybe like 60 people and it's all like that
I think it's like dinner is and it's all like little little tables and booths and I was sitting at the bars one little bar area and
The stages is like right there. I love this stage. Actually, it's like it's like heightened and right on the top there. Yeah, and
and
you see like
eight variety acts and
You get a three course meal and it's like super casual like it's actually like that you you actually get break
You're getting breaks with both right you stop watch entertainment then you get food and you have friends there like we had other friends
We're just oh, that's cool. We were just you know each course
So you could talk in between and then shut up while the show's happening back and forth. Yes. That's great. That's great
That's smart, especially nowadays, right? Give them a minute. Talk about it. Yeah. Yeah, like it was very much like it
but I was funny was so we went and saw it and
you know, it's speaker world so there's access some of these amazing acts and so the first two acts was the
This great bubble act that's famously been in their shows for forever
Where they have a person blow all kinds of different kind of crazy bubbles and make different shapes with smoke and stuff and it's beautiful
It's beautiful
Heart-touching act and then our friend Lindsey better. I think it's Howard Noddy. I think it's Howard Noddy's
Or one of it one of his students kind of brought to Spiegel world
Tin scoop reminds us that $150 is the price of a tuna sub at this subway in Orleans
These are that is a party sub though. That is a party sub
So you get to wear a hat why you eat it
Your version of a party sub
It's a regular foot log, but it comes with a hat and a hat says I spent $150 on a tuna sub
so
Next up was Lindsey better who headlined our VIP night
Doing a shorter version of that same act a book of lights
Remarkable at it right and especially she juggles the balls in the dark to that beautiful piano music the whole bit or whatever
So these are both nice acts very nice partner in it as well still no
No, it's just it's just in the short version. It's just Lindsey. Okay. No, Gary. No, Gary
And
So then the next course came out was a little break and the mater dee I guess sensing that we were
Entertainment people or something. I don't or he says this to everybody
But he's like, oh, don't worry. It gets weirder. It gets crazier
Which so that was like some bizarre warning
Was like wait what but he wasn't kidding
He was correct, okay have a drag act of a person dressed as a sexy cow
Yeah
And then the cow does a full on
Like dance throughout the entire room and then does an elaborate
striptease of
slowly
Revealing its utters
What are they what are they sequestered under like like like like like lace like lingerie and then like first like a like like
It was just looks like a regular like it looks like it's one piece like it's one
It's like utters that are are in like spandex or something like that
Then the spandex comes off and they're like a lacy udder on the cow
And then boom it's revealed both of the four udders and people just you know
Know how to cheer for burlesque so the people place goes wild when the others are revealed. Yeah. Oh, yeah, and then he shoots
milk
all over the like just
starts shooting milk all
And at one point singles on a guy just like blasted in his mouth for like 15 seconds. Oh my god
It's milk leg all over again
I
Was dying laughing. I thought it was hysterical. That's great. This month is hosted by Eddie's
She's filling in for the main host and
One point she just
Walks around with an accordion asking people for her vices and just does crowd work and just basically
Just narrates all the sexual tension in the room with everybody and their tables
Singing a song to an accordion and I just was like I love this act. She could do this anywhere. She could do this everywhere. I
Just was like get get get scoop fest tomorrow. Let's go. Yeah
accordion just walk around the strolling accordion fucking with people and it was like my favorite thing and one of my favorite things in
the night very Judy Tanuta
Yes, our IP. Yeah. Yeah. Well, that is the thing like there are people that we know
There's there are several different acts that we could point at that we that we know of over the years
Where the act is just the excuse for this talented person to be on stage. Yes
We just we just need this talented person to be out there with a microphone on so that they can be out there and do things
We need a reason for it. Here's an accordion. All right now go
And in this tiny room, they were very inventive with like finding a way to put like an aerial act in it
But they use like a side of the floor instead of the stage for it, but it's still like well lit and compelling
cool
Our friend penny is in it and she does this penny ran penny ran
There's the fabulous penny run who I always knew was a comedic burlesque artist. She does a very not comedic a very intense
Dance burlesque number in it that I was like, wow, this is a different side of penny. It was really compelling really cool
Penny is an excellent burlesque performer and in all in all
Types of it and like I think I don't want to speak for I think that she enjoys the comedic side of it
Maybe more than the kind of the classic side of it. But I mean, she's got those classic chops for sure. Yeah
It is also just like I was like this is one I left because being around speaker world in the in the
2000s and the 2010s
Boy, did the CEO really love the idea of dinner being served with acts like just kept finding every different anniversary or some kind of
Celebration need be like why don't we bring in chefs?
Get me food with entertainment, please and so I cannot this entertainment is great, but my fingers aren't greasy. You know, I
Can't feel like this is just a dream come true for him
But I actually love it like I think it's so smart for Vegas to have something like this
It is is everything everything that looks like it needs to be there's a couple things happening
I was like, oh these are things to note for like surviving the modern Vegas landscape and this is one of them
Combining the dinner entertainment experience in a place. That's the price that you would have paid for one of those experiences
And and then what happens is I guess the main host who at least is filling in for
Actually meets everyone before the show like hosts everyone in the little room pants out champagne and actually memorizes everyone's name
So throughout the show, that's a gimmick
She just turns and will while she's doing an act like actually say the person's name like in you Tom
You know like and just talk to people and I was like, oh wow, and then also our friend gypsy
Walks around with these like cards that make people ask personal questions to each other as couples
During the dinner parts of the show great and I was like again just that's it
That's a small thing
but it's a huge thing and that like we don't get to focus on ourselves during a show and this is you are making that happen and
Those are two things with this happening. I was like those two small touches
I think mean a lot for how to differentiate itself from well from Las Vegas and that is
Part and parcel to the modern media landscape and the attention spanscape and all that kind of thing
You know, we're all we're all dipping into our phones every five minutes. I'm as guilty of it as the next person and
This lets you do it whilst not being rude. I think a phone dip everybody phone dip
My phone's not even turning on what the hell? Oh, there it goes. Yeah
I've gotten a couple of new emails
None of them look important. Okay, I'm back
Alright, I got a message from Brogan that I'll have to get back to them
Leaving it on red
I get it another thing. I'm very curious about
Because it's way outside of my taste
but I get it is
the Vanderpump casino
What a focus? Yes. Yes. See the Cromwell is turning into the Vanderpump
Really? Yeah, holy shit
and I'm curious if it will work because for instance one of the things like
Vegas has been notoriously dead. It had a big spike this past weekend because of BravoCon. Oh
Yes, so all those shows that are on Bravo
They had a gigantic convention in town and a lot of people came to town for BravoCon
It was really was like one of those newer conventions that took over the town. Oh cool
and so like I'm curious if
like niche
fandom like niche community fandom
can
Fill hotels on a regular basis instead of a convention like right. Well, right is the Vanderpump reach
Such that those people will like to because basically treat themselves to the experience in the hotel
Of course the Vanderpump will be at the hotel, you know
like will that be enough of a niche thing to
Fuel because it's the only innovation I'm seeing in the casino space
It's I mean that one specifically might be because there there are already I think three or four
Large Vanderpump bars in casinos. There's one in Caesars. There's one in the flamingo
That one in Caesars has been there forever and it is always busy
Yeah
It used to be a different thing and now it's been Vanderpump for quite a few years now
And yeah
I mean even just this like yesterday when I walked past it
There was just a giant line out the door of people waiting to get into it
Yeah, it is not slowed down. There's one in Paris as well
So I mean there are a couple of those and I know they're always busy
So it really might be and and the brand is just kind of like nice decor and good food
Good drinks and luxury. What a brand what niche products. Do you think could bolster a full casino Matt?
What niche fandoms do you think could hold up a whole casino like that?
I mean, I'm telling you right now if Magic the Gathering is popular as it is and Post Malone is as popular as he is
If Post Malone were to somehow do one of these like David Blaine like residencies
and
And tie that in with Magic the Gathering events and you had to just simply come up with events outside of Post Malone's
Weekends, I bet that would do well enough for a small casino. I should point out that the Cromwell is a small casino
The Cromwell is on the great location
And it certainly could use something. The Cromwell was not itself an overachieving casino. It basically was just drays
Just drays. It just was a nightclub. It was that it was the casino that was underneath drays. Yeah
Yeah, no, San Diego Comic-Con super Nova girls mentioning SDCC was thinking of moving to Vegas
Well, I know Evo thrives in Vegas
Evolution the evolution fighting championship, you know, that's it
I think I think some kind of if you could properly umbrella nerddom
Right because that's actually what you're also trying to innovate is not just going out to Vegas, but staying in that space, right?
But are you looking for a year-round kind of attraction? That's what I'm curious about
Oh, yeah stuff makes sense to me as a convention standpoint
But this Vanderpump thing makes sense for it because the Vanderpumps are always there, right?
Well, there was that talk of the Atari Hotel that fell through right? Yeah
So something along those lines, I think a video game based
property could work
Yeah video game fandom like you could be it could be like one floor would be all fighting games
one floor could be shooters one floor could be
competitive COD
What I'm really kind of poking is like what what that is a great way to buy floors of fortnightly
Go against the grain of what's currently
One of the factors is currently hurting Las Vegas, which is people are feeling
Totally nickels and dimes right price. Yeah, absolutely priced out. They don't feel like the value is there and
Also, like because we are so feast and famine with these crazy events
So like if you wanted to say come to Vegas just to check out, you know a couple of you know
Area 15 a couple of museums or you know meet some friends for a bachelor party or whatever
And if it's the same weekend as a Raiders game, you're fucked if it's the same weekend as a Taylor Swift concert
You're fucked because every hotel raises their rates for these marquee events f1, right?
Like you you and so now like and people people aren't planning their personal events around those kinds of things
No one's gonna be like I want to my bachelor party in April. Oh, wait, there's a there's an event. I should move it
They're gonna go somewhere else. They're gonna say not Vegas, you know, by the way having Monday night football
Then a week of f1 then a Sunday football game at the Raiders Stadium
Along with everything else that's already going on is too much stuff
It's too much stuff. I agree
We found it. It is way too fucking much
I'm working for F, you know, I'm working for Spiegelworld for f1 this year. I'm hosting
Their ski lodge with Casey Wilson. Oh great into the show. So Casey and I have been hired to be
hosts
for the ski lodge
Which is a an additional attraction within the Mercedes tent for people by the Mercedes experience
And so we've been working on that all day and I've been I went to the track yesterday
And I'm going to the track again today and we're commuting from the office to carpool and it's just a nightmare
Yes
Get in and out and I try to race home and there's a Raiders game and I was like, oh, I said
I'm like really good at finding back roads, but the back roads were slammed because of the Raiders game and I was like
Oh my god this town
And of course, it's a monsoon this week here as well
So we were we had to go yesterday for really? Oh, yeah
it's been hard hard rain for four days and
The the lodge itself is a the attraction is not a roofed thing. It's an open air thing
So we we we then Casey never confused like no, they still want us to come in to the track and I was like, okay
Okay, and then we so let me have a huddle up in this one area that there was still kind of building the whole
There's still building the whole thing at one point Emily Wendler
Who's who's one of the one of the writers on it was like it feels like the race up Thursday more should be done
Then what's I'm seeing?
Still very much putting together
One of those things where they all come in at the last minute you go
Just then they're done. That's it. I think you're confusing it with the pit crew
No, the pit crook is the ones who build the whole thing, right?
They set everything up and then finally the pit crew comes in and just like oh, yeah sure
Done
So we're in this one area and we're working and the power goes out because of the rain is just everywhere
And then as we're doing boom like a leak like a big stream of water leak just burst through one of the
Shit
This town
Time there is a major rainstorm. It is just hilarity
Yeah, and it's not even I I would love to say that it's people's fault
I really don't think it is because it's so dry and so hot here all the time
So all of the seals like they dry out and rot and everything
Yes, listen that dried out
Seal can you hold any water back at all or you to dry it out?
Is that what happened to his face
Hold back the water got it right out
Yeah, no, it's been it's been a lot. It's been a whole lot this week. Yeah
But I can't wait. I have more story about wait till after the weekends over to tabulate all my stories for
It's been a really funny event to work. It's had some friends outside. They've been
Setting up speakers for for the whole event there. They run the sound systems for for the whole event and
Yeah, they were I was texting with him yesterday. They were trying to
They had found a roll of clear plastic and they were trying to clean it. They're this queen. Okay
They had found this role of this queen and they were trying to waterproof their golf cart so they could get from site to site
Absolutely soaking wet
Try to clip up this queen on the front of the golf cart to be turning it into a windshield and have doors
Yeah
We're leaving the track and then like one of the carts came pulling up one of the guys working F1
Was like pull up and he slowed down he goes. So don't worry
I'm not gonna get you wet and then keeps driving and I was like, well you can give us a ride
You could also not leave us walking in the rain
Like I'll take you're not splashing us as like a bare minimum courtesy and I appreciate it but
Maybe also drive us to the parking lot
It is Vegas rain is
Vegas is snow for sure. Yes, it is really really crazy
You know who else gets really confused when they get wet. That's the following sponsor
Hot mud skipper and that's for the mud skipper scoop in 2021 today shows brought to you by hot mud skipper
I need some water
Anybody got some water and I'm trying to skip the mud but in the mud it's just dirt
I have some water. Oh, can I have some please? I'm so hot
Here oh, oh Jesus just stop breathing
That's so much better
And her hey scoops a check out
Drive a couple kids home the other day
after they were hanging out my with my with my sons at the at my house and
One of them was like just
like sniffing like
Like their kids, right? So there are other phones
just like like alright some other guys dad's gonna drive us home time to bury our face and phones and
just just
Know and I was like, hey pal, can I give you a tissue goes? No, I'm okay. And I was like you're not you're not
You're sniffing like a demon, please stop you're something at a normal pace
Whatever you're trying to prevent is it is nigh the event. The nose the nasal event is here
There is drippage
Roast oh I was all right. We went down south this last week to to visit with my family
And I got to hang out with my little niece my little my little five-year-old niece and you know as great as it is
Yeah, you see you see the kiddo and that's really fun. And and you know, she's she's growing up. She's five now
She's she's you know, just a person. She remembers things she could talk to you about things. It's great
On the other hand these fucking kids and their germs
I
Like should cough a little bit. I feel out God cover your mouth
Like now, you know like like like
When adults here like oh so and so got sick, you know, we think at school and you're like, yeah
It's going around when you hear that. Yeah, it's going around. You don't picture that but that's exactly what everyone's saying
yes
it's in their ability to cover their coughs and
Just they just don't do it. No
Well, I'm hoping to stay well during this holiday season, but I've been busy as a one-legged man in an ass-kicking contest
It's awesome though. My classes have picked up. I just started my second level one this Monday
then I went hot taught my free class over at the duty last night, which was great fun and
And I got my level two class
Locked in starting next week next Tuesday. So I'll be teaching two classes a week moving forward
Which is awesome. I I'm just astounded. It's it's great. I'm super excited for this community to keep growing and
Yeah, there we go. Just make the drive Jason. Just do it. Just come on out. Come on out to Pittsburgh
Do you have like hand sanitizer like what are you doing to promise to keep this not like a germ germ thing?
You know what I mean? Well now that it is truly getting into the cold times
Yeah, I think I'm gonna have to just hand sanitize a little more here and there and you know, I bring water
I bring my vitamin C drops like always keep myself poppin the vitamin C drops
And yeah, have you thought about teaching improv over zoom? You'd love that. God damn it, dude
The difference is staggering the difference is staggering
Staggering I feel energized after class is not drained. It's crazy. It's crazy
I won't I won't think I'll ever do it again. I don't think I can I don't think it's I think it's unethical at this point
It's just not even right to do
Talked into it a few times
Yeah, and after one I was like literally like just like bleary-eyed like like just like oh god
and it was like an hour and a half and
After they're like the team says that was great. Are you right? Of course?
Yeah, because they just fucking vampires your whole soul. Yeah, cuz you have to give like I mean
I give a lot in my classes, but Jesus to get it through the screen is like oh
God damn it
Yeah, no scooper never girl. The monthly poll zooms will not be improv classes. No, no, no, no by the by
I'm about to set up the invites for that as soon as I can figure that out
Exactly, which levels I need to send the invites out to and how nice that which is the right ones
I'm thinking day after Thanksgiving
That Friday night take a shot because people will be free. Yeah, we'll see how it goes. So
Yeah
Mm-hmm. All right while I was out of town. I really missed my bidet. Oh
Asshole really missed my bidet. I fucking bet dude, Jacob being away from it for a few days
I just might I was like, oh now I have to take a whole shower if I want my asshole to get clean
I am still waiting for that day that glorious day when I can get a full-on Japanese toilet installed in this place
Yeah, I really want one with all the bells and whistles
That's gonna be that's gonna be when I know I've made it that and a pinball machine
Those are the great thing about having all the bells and whistles on there is that everybody in the house knows when you're taking a shit
Who cares they can because they can hear all the bells and whistles. Yeah
Paul shit again, well mine's a Japanese toilet, so it doesn't sound like that. It sounds different
I'm a Japanese toilet. I don't sound like this. It's just take one. It's just one big gong when you when you drop the main load
Oh, I would like that a lot
Yeah, what's worse is I'm like kept bring it up while he was there my god, he really misses bidet
He won't stop talking about it
This paper our water bill
All the showers he's taking is just I wonder why he asked me to buy him a ketchup dispensing bottle
Pull the garden hose in through the bath
Yeah
You do not want to do that on a cold day
Before you get around there be everywhere you kink the hose you kick the hose there at the very end
Kicking that hose that's for sure
Yeah, you just put your thumb in there and just direct that right on up kink hose and club
I'm gonna get my butt clean with the kink hose and club
I'm gonna clean my asshole with a thumb on the end
Squirt and all that water up my bum. That'll do it kink hose and club
Let's do a little jock vs. Nerd. How about it fellas?
Fuck yeah, I'm on the hunt for balls
The hunt for balls
We got a scooper to come out today from Smitty scoop Smitty says
Gentlemen, my last scooper. He was bonkers Paul didn't get any daily doubles and one with 5200 points
Jacob set a record with seven incorrect answers and finished last with negative six thousand
So I felt obligated to prepare another scooper D so that Jacob could redeem himself. Thank you Smitty
Here are the updated Smitty scooper D statistics all-time victories Matt 13 Paul for Jacob eight all-time points
Matt has thirty six or thirty three thousand six hundred Paul has negative twenty two thousand six hundred and Jacob is down to six thousand four
Hundred and a calendar year twenty twenty five victories. We've each won two
We've each won two. All right
My most winning year clearly. That's right. That's right. The categories are acronyms women multiple choice and random
Oh, it's me. I'm first. I'll start with I'll start with women. Give me women for $400, please
Jacob say focus on the game, please
What? Oh shit
June 21st 2018
Jacinda art Ardern became just the second elected head of government to give birth while in office
She is the former prime minister of a Canada be the Netherlands see New Zealand or D, Norway
All right, I think there's no way I'll give birth to a baby while in office
Are you Canadian? Yeah, it's right. I'm from Canada
All the way from the great white north, huh? Yeah all the way there
Well, I'll guess New Zealand then see New Zealand. It is New Zealand
Okay
Benazir
Bhutto of Pakistan was the first world leader to give birth in office. All right. Oh
So this person was the second one. That was the first one. I got you cool Paul. You're up. Oh
I'll go
multiple choice, please for 400
When he was growing up in France in the 1950s, which Irish author and playwright often drove Andre the Giant to school
James Joyce Oscar Wilde George Bernard Shaw none of the above all of the above
Wasn't it is Beckett or Joyce I can't remember who though
I honestly don't remember who the real one is anymore
I'll go. Oh
I'll go James. No Beckett. I thought it was Shakespeare. I thought Shakespeare drove. No
They bonded over their mutual love of cricket
Cricket, huh?
You like you like when the ball hits a small ball to the other ball and pretty great. I like rigor
I know it. That's what hey
Joel, but not sure I want to write a card on a hot tin roof with you
We're afraid of Virginia Woolf
Pop it the brain hidden you don't know anything about being a guy on a hot tin roof
I
Am the king I'm the greatest and no one to be me
Keep the belt forever. I really love cricket. I mean it
Thank You Samuel Beckett
Fight me in the ring. Go ahead. I'll tear you apart. I
Thought the line was would anyone like a peanut
Where they were like a parent is
Buddy with a peanut. I'm a poet and you know it Jacob against my better judgment. I'm gonna proceed with the game
All right. All right interesting. I'll go acronyms 400, please
What is AIDS short for a short for it short for the time you have left to live?
Hey, I don't suck
Acquired immunodeficiency syndrome
Acquired immune deficiency syndrome is absolutely correct
It's me I'll try a random for 400
What is the nickname of professional dart player Oliver Bates?
That he was barred from using at the 2024 World Dart Championship by the
PDC
He's known as the motherfucking king of goddamn dogs. Oh
No, I actually know this one everybody calls this guy Jeffrey Epstein
It is awkward these days for that guy Oh
Oliver's we should hit a different nickname right now. It's on redacted files the cowards
Thank You Andre I'm redacted I'm passing Paul, it's got to be master Bates. Oh
Sure, it's gotta be master Bates. Let's try it
Master Oliver master Bates there. It is
Right there. It's right your hand. I was gonna go with I was gonna go with old brown eyes, but there you go
Old shit finger Bates
It can't be I can't be shit finger. That's how I won my first championship. Come on. Come on
I put a little shit on my finger. Help me throw my dart. I'm the shit finger
You make a good argument sir, you can use your nickname it comes the shit finger murderer
That's it he has the he has an entry song already written
The ball you're up
In June Kearstee Coventry became the first female president of the IOC
What country did she represent at the Olympics Australia Canada South Africa or Zimbabwe?
I'll go with Australia. Kearstee. Sorry, Australia
I'm sorry. It's Zimbabwe. She won seven Olympic medals as a swimmer and is the most
Decorated African Olympian and you'd know that if you had any fucking taste Paul. I don't study the Olympics
I only I only work in the squared circle
I'll call me
Okay, Jacob, let's let Andre cook here, okay
Andre still going that no
What is NASA short for North American free trade agreement
For the moon didn't quite method
Not a call I have no I used to know this but no pass passes to me
National aeronautics and space association association is wrong. I
Think association is wrong
National aeronautics in space. Oh
If you're giving somebody something Jacob
Non adversarially no
If you're about to give me a shot, what are you gonna do to me you're going to
stick a needle into you sure I
Don't know what if it's national aeronautics and space administration
Administration, that's it. Yeah, what did I say?
Association association. Yeah, I knew that you fool
Yeah
I'll try random for a hundred
What is the nickname of professional dart player Tim Pucey
2025 world dark championship by the PC Tim shit finger Pucey
One in the stink one in the pink Pucey. It's also master master Pucey
Gary
It's it's Tim dry Pucey. I
Think
Dry and difficult, you know
You know a lot of Gary Gary Pucey can't be good
It's all about the Archer endocrine system
Talk about talk about buttered sausage
Talk about what that does to you
Do you know what Pucey stands for Pucey Pucey also stands for Pucey. I didn't very creative
I'm passing Paul. What do you think it is? Oh
My god dirty till dirty puce
Tim the clit Pucey
Show me the clip no
There's an imaginary dart player you can't find a man there
Matt it passes to you. It's a smack that
Grab them by the PC
What you say your nickname is fist the
Fist of Pucey
That was honestly
the most underrated
Man with no name trilogy
entry I thought
Yeah, a fistful of Pucey
For a few pussies more
Tim super tight
Comfortably tight, it's his name unwashed Pucey
Matt do you have any other guesses? Where is my bidet? I need to wash my Tim 70s Bush Pucey
Makes me want to watch darts. We would have got there. Eventually. We were dancing all around it. We were dancing all around it
Paul you're up. Oh god women again, please Tim the butte the blue
An Oreo featuring chocolate and cinnamon cream atop a layer of sweetened condensed milk cream sandwiched between two chocolate cinnamon cookies
Was named after what former Disney teen idol Miley Cyrus Sabrina Carpenter Selena Gomez or Zendaya?
These were the Selena Gomez Oreos, but Selena Gomez Oreos is absolutely correct
Yeah, the Paul Oreo microwave hot dog cream with strawberry
Mmm, that wouldn't be the worst thing
You're wrong. It would be the worst thing. Did you guys ever do a sleeve of Selena's?
Never did in my mouth or my Pucey
Dealers choice I
Will take acronyms for 1200. What is PETA short for Pucey's red?
Court for bread
People for the ethical treatment of animals
People for the ethical treatment of animals is absolutely correct or people eating tasty animals either way either way
I'll close out acronyms 2000
What is scuba short? Oh, man?
That would be subterranean
concubines under
Brett Allen
Who of course was the old music conductor at my college Brett Allen
It's all about him
underwater breathing apparatus
Ikea
No, it's our rule our rule holds Jacob. Yeah, I think so self-contained underwater breathing apparatus is always correct. Yeah, Paul
women
for 2000
Which of the Golden Girls actors had the most husbands be Arthur Betty white Estelle Getty?
Rue McClanahan and then the answer the answer put into the question
Estelle Getty had six Rue McClanahan had three Betty white had to be Arthur had one so Paul
I'll ask again which of the golden girls actors had the most husbands
I'm gonna go. Well, you have a guess. It's already getting I'm gonna go with Estelle Getty. Let's see. Oh
I'm sorry Rue McClanahan. What? Oh
Six Rue McClanahan three two one. What what I think they just fucked with you fine
Think Rue McClanahan had six Betty white had three be author had two and Estelle Getty had one. Oh, well says I don't know
Oh, I think they're they're maybe making fun of their own scooperty where they actually wrote the answer into the question. Ah
Sneak. Oh, yeah, that was Smitty's who did that. That's true
Matt
Random please for 1200
Humble brag the mother of which East Street band member was my seventh grade social studies teacher at Thompson
Junior High School in Middletown, New Jersey
I
Shouldn't just guess I guess I can guess
You do you have that option? Yeah. Yeah. I'm looking at the scores as I contemplate
Oh
Yeah, I've got 2400 Matt's got 1600 Paul's got zero
I think max and there's one daily double left, I think
Just I don't I don't think it wasn't Clarence Clemens. I don't think his he's his mom taught in Middletown
Okay, like my gut says Max Weinberg, but
Your gut always says Max Weinberg, that's true. Your gut is constantly talking about Max Weinberg or Gary w tail
I'm gonna pass. Oh
That passes to me
You already named more East Street band members than I can
Specifically you've named all the street band members that I can Gary I'm passing to that Gary Pusey, of course Paul
Maybe little Steven. I don't know
You want to guess you guess that I'll go max Weinberg mighta max
No, it was little
Fart my blood is Mary Van Zant offered an a memorize all of the US presidents in order and I got that a
man
Little Stevens mama was a teacher
Awesome, that's me. I'll try. I'm not fucking random 2,000
Jacob in the dick hole what company just announced that it has instituted a new 10
4 program with its workers
That's a 10 hour workday
For four days a week. Oh
I see. Oh, I've done that before I did not like that a friend of mine used to do did it with his company
And it's doing very well. I don't think this is I bet it works better for companies
It doesn't work well for entertainment. We didn't for 12 back when we did our
Alien stuff because it took so long to get into the makeup and oh, yeah, it helped keep
Yeah, it was good. It worked for us. Yeah. I know there's some places in other countries they do
720s but
720s yeah
Come coming to us a state near you I'm afraid
Um, I Google
Target oh
It's not the 10 hours four days a week thing when a customer is within 10 feet display welcoming body language
Was within four feet verbal greeting or offer personal assistance. Yeah, that went over like a lead balloon. I can tell you everybody
Everybody was like eat shit
First of all, is there any onboarding and by that I mean so like what are you gonna get like a tape measure and start?
Like make sure when there's nothing I mean
Yeah, I mean that just it seems like a bad idea all it's not as though
The the current directives are like scowl at everyone entering the store
You know, it's it's nothing. It's not it's all common-sense shit, but then also
It's very clear that they have no idea what's going on on the ground level of their stores or they're just really trying to
Shine some shit up for the investors cuz boy. Oh boy things is a rocky road a rocky road
Oh great. Well, that's only change the scores Matt's ahead with
Sorry, I just didn't want spoilers. I'm a target
Stockholders and I have a meeting coming up. So great. No spoilers Paul. I want to leave it all for the call
Okay, I'll keep it for the call Matt does like those investment calls
Score check Matt has 1600. I'm down to zero now after that daily double and Paul has a negative 1200
But it's Paul's turn Paul. You have multiple choice for 800 1200 to 2000
I gotta go 2000 to get back into the positive baby
Which college town is famous for its pepperoni rolls?
Manhattan, Kansas Morgan town, West Virginia Stillwater, Oklahoma or Tuscaloosa, Alabama
Well, I know it's a big thing here. It's a big thing here and we're close to West Virginia. So I'll go with okay
All right. Let's see it
Morgantown West Virginia is absolutely correct similar to a stromboli but smaller and less cheese mid-atlantic market has the best ones. I
Do not care for pepperoni rolls get out of my zone leave my zoom. Okay
Up Paul has left Matt. You're up
Let's see here if I I can seal the victory with 1200
That is true. I'll do 1200
All right, multiple choice for 1200 from Sesame Street's inception in
1969 until his retirement in 2018
Carol Spiney played what two Sesame Street characters Big Bird and Oscar Big Bird and Grover
Count and Grover or Grover and Oscar. Oh
Man, let's see. I believe he played Big Bird for sure
Okay. So now is it Big Bird and Grover or Big Bird in Oscar?
Mm-hmm
Now if I get this wrong that I'm dumb that I put myself in second place. I'm a fool. I should have an 800. I
Don't think this is why you're dumb. Oh good point
I'm going to say
Grover Big Bird and Grover be be Big Bird and Grover is
Incorrect
That is why you rarely saw both of them at the same time that was my lots of for picking Grover
Let's see here Paul has 800 Matt has 400 I have zero
There is a multiple choice question for 800 left and it's mine for the tie
What global news company was started in?
1950 when it developed a prototype news service using homing pigeons and electric telegraphy
to transmit messages between Brussels and
ancient
Bloomberg
routers Sky News or UPI
Ah
Let's see news company
They used homing pigeons. That's got to be Sky News, right? Let's go Sky News. See it's a good guess
It's a wrong one Reuters
And Penn loves this fact
There you go according to this. Oh, there you go
That is the game Paul wins with 800 points Matt's in second with 400 and I'm in third with negative 800 that comes from
Smitty scoop. Thank you so much Smitty scoop
If you want to make us a scooper t or a price of strike jock versus nerd or an obelisk jock versus nerd
We could always use some more head over to preaching fun comm. Nope. That's wrong
Head over to hey scoops comm hey scoops comm go make us a jock versus nerd send us in some scoop mail
You can do all those things right over there at hey scoops comm, please
That's right
Now we got to thank some people. Yes reaching fun comm
We have so many people to thank because we had issues with her with our patreon site this month
Man, yeah, we got some people to thank here patreon change the rules so people can't download stuff to the computers
They send them an email with a download instead
What it patrons is fucking dick about things
We're gonna change things for the sake of changing things
Yeah, but I want to thank people who are dicks. These people are the opposite dicks. They're
buttholes uses
I want to thank signature curl scoop the micro scoop for shaping
We all scoop for mark mclean unbanned scoop one small scoop for man a ranch slunk a scoop of root canal Aaron Aaron Boyd
Aaron Wendling Adam golf Adam Stickney AJ be actually my sore a la scoop
6666 all-star scoop America Scott scoop Andrea Anderson Andrew J Hughes Andrew Koenig as you also Chuck Andy cheek Angela Chan
Angry face scoop and and foods. Thank you so much
Well following individuals are soaking wet with Vegas rain Ben gal Ben Smith Ben Sherman scoop big load of scoop
Big sexy the digital nomad bike scoop Bill Beatty blue line scoop
bosun scoop B OB Bobby Becerra Brad Martin Brendan light Brendan Allen
Brandon Maddox aka an Arco scoop Brian Richard Brooks Lyle Brian McLeod Brian Traves Buster Kamikaze
Cwik Cali ghost Cameron Hall
Canadian scoop crystal captain James T scoop and cargo van killer
I want to thank the fine people who are all angel investors in the house of shards. That's Anton
Apple scoop Aramis are evens are less a wall scoop bad pirate scoop birdie
Bart vonk base camp scoops BB hermit BB
I'm sorry bearded scoop three bear scoop BJ Joyer Belgian triple scoop Ben and Ben Dennis
Big thanks to all these people who are funding the opening of the new shit finger casino
Carolyn Albert, Cassie Rice Charles Eaton Charles Jishakie Charlie Thompson chasing the dragon scoop Chelsea far
Chris Bartschi Chris Ellis Chris fit Chris Fisher Chris Jackson Chris Gerog Chris Kay Chris
melanchon Christine Elsasser and Christine star
Thank you. And of course the following scoops have miraculously clean assholes with or without a bidet. That's Christopher
Hey, what's possible?
Christie Salinas chronicler scoop CJ Magnetta Clayton Shoney clown in a brothel coach rat bastard coconut time travel
coffee bean scoop Colleen Fisher Colton st. Mary or Satbury
Cone photo with scooped her Corianna Chimura corny scoop counselor Matt country scoop court Myers
Craig defarmer Craig little cream city scoop Chris mayor cup of scoop Dan
It's Dan thirsty three Dan Martin Daniel Loser Daniel Mattis Ferreira then Danny old wine
Darren Cunningham Darth scooper Dave serial Dave Hanson Dave slusher David Johnson David a small David gravel
David Kaye David Peterson David Sorenson David Walker dead Laszlo and Derek Dozier. Thank you all so much
Thank you so much
If you want to be thanked on air or get all kinds of different prizes and rewards headed over to preaching fun
Calm and support us today
Come visit Preachingfun.com
It's better than hanging with your mom
Or if you're a junior high English teacher was named mrs. Bon Jovi head on over to fartsinabag.biz
That's fartsinabag.biz that along with preaching fun calm it takes you over to our patreon page
We're for as little as three dollars a month. You can help keep this show on the air. That's right
This show is entirely possible and it's entirely made possible by our patreon subscribers
So if you think this show is worth more than zero dollars as little as three dollars a month that gets you into the club
You can do it monthly. You can do it yearly if you do it. Yeah, you get it. You didn't even steeper discount there
It's all real nice but head over there preaching fun calm farts in a bag dot biz if you think this show is worth more than zero
Dollars if you do only feel that this show is worth zero dollars
And if that is your feeling I get it you could still do something to help us out
You can tell somebody about us tell one person one person only we don't do a pyramid scheme here people
No, we do an obelisk scheme. There's one person. It is a vertical growth
Generation here. There's a tiny pyramid on top. Don't look at it. Don't talk about it. Don't do anything with it
It's an obelisk scheme find that one person that you think is gonna really dig on this weird thing that we got happening over here
Tell them about it. Help them join up. It'll be great. I
Want to thank Bassey the Portuguese scoop who's saying he hasn't been thanked
He's telling us to check it now here
Which is not the best way to handle it unless you want to handle the way I just handled it
We'll get it
But definitely I will not remember to look into it from here
So shoot us an email if you want us to look into it, but thank you Bassey and also you can
See the Portuguese scoop there you go
Annie is the one who tees all that up for us. So alright at any rate. Thanks for seeing everybody stay safe out there
We love you, and we'll see you soon
So people just wipe their asses with toilet paper all the time
Is that how the rest lives?
We're Breaching Fun!
Oh